d'histoire j'accueille les grands
champions français de patinage
artistique sarah abitbol et stéphane
bernadis
bravo même très bien
le barça attend une étape assez de force
qui les a mis la main sur la shopping
c'est passionnant compliqué d'en bas ne
rigole pas sinon dans la rue demain veut
dire fascinant choupinette c'est pas le
nom qui périssent et s'est bâtie c'est
dommage que vous soyez plus au csa sinon
vous l'auriez à peu pris là parce que
nous avons comme stagiaire enregistrer
des émissions de serre 10 et humanité au
scope marcherait pas ce jour là bien
alors sahara bonsoir
stéphane bonsoir donc mercredi 24
janvier 2001 vous avez gagné la médaille
de bronze des championnats d'europe de
patinage artistique à bratislava
vous avez été devancé par deux couple de
russes comme d'habitude comme d'hab
ouais enfin ils sont pas imbattables
quand même il irait bien par les avoir
on va les avoir
on va travailler plus mais déjà prêts
déterminés ça on va regarder comment ça
s'est passé
magnéto serge enfants